جديد نقلت رويترز عن وزير الداخليه
الباكستانيه ان الشرطه ستعتقل اليوم رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان وستقدمه للعداله
وقد تجمع انصار خان امام منزله بعد وصول
فريقا من الشرطه لاعتقاله بناء على امر
قضائي ونقل مراسل الجزيره عن مسؤول حكوميا
ان التدافع بدا حين اعترض مؤيدو خان رجال
شرطه كانوا يحاولون تسليم خان مذكره
ومذكره جلب لحضور جلسه استماع في المحكمه
من جهته طلب عمران خان من انصاره مواصله
التظاهر لما سماه ليلى الحريه والاستقلال
حتى لو تم اعتقاله
معنى الالم من اسلام اباد مراسل الجزيره
سمير النمري كيف يتفاعل هذا الموضوع سمير
في اسلام اباد مع تجمع هؤلاء الانصار امام
منزل عمران خان ومع تسليمه مذكره محاولات
السلطات تسليمه مذكره الاعتقال
هادئه جدا باستثناء بيان لشرطه اسلام
اباده التي اتهمت فيها انصار الرئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان بمحاوله
الاعتداء على قوات الشرطه واصابه خمسه من
افرادها خلال محاولتهم تسليم مذكره
استجواب او
بامر قضائي لعمران خان في منزله في مدينه
لاهور ولكن انصار عمران خان كما تقول
الشرطه تصد لها واعتدوا عليها بينما يقول
انصار عمران خان ان الشرطه اعتدت عليهم
بقسوه بالهراوات وكذلك
بالغاز المسير للدموع كان عمران خان قد
القى كلمه مقتضبه عبر صفحاته على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي دعا فيها انصاره للنزول
الى الشارع والتظاهر خاصه فيما اذا تمكنت
من اعتقاله هذا هذه الليله هناك حاله من
الغليان في محيط منزل عمران خان حيث يجتمع
المئات من انصاره في محاوله لصد الشرطه
التي تحاول الوصول الى منزل عمران خان
بينما هناك ايضا بعض الخروج في المسيرات
الصغيره في بعض
المدن كما رصدت من خلال مواقع التواصل
جوهر المشكله ايمان يتمثل في ان المحكمه
تريد عمران خان ان ياتي اليها الى قاعات
الى قاعاتها للتقاضي في تهم تتعلق ببيعه
لهدايا حكوميه بينما يرفض عمران خان
المثول في قاعات المحكمه معللا ذلك بخشيته
على حياته ومستدلا بما تعرض له في نوفمبر
الماضي من محاوله اغتيال ويريد ان تكون
هذه المحاكمات عبر الفيديو المحاكمات ليست
قليله وليست قضيه واحده هناك نحو 36 قضيه
مرفوعه ضده في عدد من المحاكم الابتدائيه
وهو يلجا دائما الى محاكم عليا لاستصدار
عفو او مذكره اعفاء
الحضور وتاجيل المحاكمه شكرا لك سمير
النمري كنت معنا من اسلام ابد